everyone has the right to recline but
there's a polite way to do it I don't
agree be aware of your surroundings
before reclining peek behind you and see
what the situation is and nicely ask if
that person Minds I am very anti-recline
I'm pretty Pro recline if the person in
front of me reclines I'm allowed to
recline I know but the thing is is like
there's always going to be somebody who
can't recline and so for them like I I
just don't feel like chairs on airplanes
should recline and I know this is like a
thought a hot take that not everyone
agrees with Brian thinks I'm crazy
because even me leaning all the way back
and then someone's chair being in my
like that's not comfortable okay
but I'm saying if the chair in front of
you has reclined you will stay up right
no then I'll recline right but like I
just wish the person in front of
me wouldn't recline okay fair but like
my my stance is if the person in front
of me has reclined I will recline I just
I think reclining is inhumane like I'm
so against it I think that they should
take it out I don't think that it's fair
I understand